last time you were on the show you
showed your medical marijuana card and
yes and I heard and I heard that you
that that that clip got around and that
people come up to you everywhere and now
they you're kind of famous now for a lot
of other things but also force don't
even add the just affirm of other things
as if I would right away go I'm famous
for more than pot I've known you I've
known for a while like you would have
been all over me
I was yeah I shut up I was here last
time and I was talking about pot and
although my kids tell me to call it weed
all right so I was talking about weed
and I want him to start smoking indica I
think it would be good for him not
before the show but to help him sleep go
to bed at night all that stuff Whoopi
Goldberg got me hooked anyhow she
actually did what if she your dealer
with what we called brick cafi yeah so I
talked about it with you Wow
I get offered weed constantly everywhere
I go oh I sign you on Conan here I saw
you on code here again your space work
isn't good no one gives you excuse me to
be here you go no here you go what is
this no actually that's the where's your
weed
the way I know the way you just played
that is they handed me a barrel of weed
and then they went downstairs what story
yes no I was doing accurate they give me
big boxes full of stuff I have a friend
here I gave it to her
I'm like oh here take all this well
they're giving me give it to me always
too much weed
well now you're famous for having a lot
of weed that you don't need we should
wrap it up
[Applause]
you